there is a new surgery being performed
by the align
surgical associates based in san
francisco i know you're gonna be shocked
to hear that
uh to nullify sex quote nullification
creates a relatively continuous and
mostly
unbroken transition from the abdomen
down to the genital area
enabling gender non-conforming patients
to enjoy a body that looks closer on the
outside
to the way they feel on the inside
so it turns you into a ken doll
or a barbie doll you know where your
pelvis is just completely flat
it just not only mutilates your genitals
to look different than they
currently look it just tries to erase
them
entirely and this is in the name of
health
if i walked into a doctor's office today
and i said you know i feel as though i
only have one arm
they say well michael you manifestly
have two arms i say
i know that you're saying that but
that's very hurtful to me because i
identify as someone with one arm and
even if
physically even if by an accident of
birth i was i was assigned two arms at
birth
i know that deep down in my true self
i'm a one armed man so i need you to
perform a surgery and cut off my arm
to make me feel on the outside more like
i feel on the inside
i would at least today i would be
committed to a mental institution for
saying that
because that is crazy talk you can't no
doctor today
as far as i know would perform that
surgery
that would violate the hippocratic oath
doctors are
supposed to at first at least do no harm
then they're trying to help you
when you mutilate perfectly functioning
organs you are harming people
however if i go in and instead of saying
hey doctor i want you to cut my arm off
if i said hey i want you to cut off a
far more sensitive part
many many doctors in the country would
do this they would
they would mutilate me if i asked them
to and
in some cases they would encourage me to
do that because of kooky
cultish theories about sex and gender
this i i think this sort of surgery
underscores a point that conservatives
have not wanted to accept for a long
time but increasingly we are
we have to say no to certain things we
should not allow that to happen we
should use
big government and regulations to stop
private citizens and private businesses
like doctor's offices
from doing that it's not enough to say
hey if you want to
chop off your organs and your limbs
that's fine just don't make me pay for
it no it's not fine it's wrong it's
actually wrong it's evil it's unjust you
shouldn't do it
it's not compassionate to the people who
are very confused to want this done
it's not good for society it's contrary
to the practice of medicine
it's contrary to justice and truth and
goodness and beauty and the american way
don't do it you have to you have to be
comfortable banning things
if you want to preserve freedom you need
to say
no to licentiousness if you want to
preserve free speech you have to say
no you have to censor speech that
undermines free speech
this is apparently a controversy this
wouldn't have been a controversial
thesis
even 50 years ago this is apparently a
controversial thesis today
and one that i advance in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now
pre-order it's a great book to read by
the way
while you are sort of sitting out
relaxing trying to bring
together all of the craziness of this
world trying to focus
not to harp too much on the creepy
gender nullification surgery
but these sickos at the alliance
surgical associates the san francisco
doctors group that's that's turning
humans into kendall's
they perform other surgeries too they'll
they'll
perform surgeries where they will you
know if you're a woman you go in
where they will sort of construct an
organ that looks
like a like a phallus but they'll keep
your
your actual genitals there too so you
you'll just be
you'll look more like a hermaphrodite
and they'll do the same thing for men
this is not this is not the purpose of
medicine
the purpose of medicine is to take
things that are not functioning and make
them function
appropriately or to make them function
better
if your kidneys aren't working well then
they're going to have some interventions
put you on dialysis make your
kidneys function a little bit better if
your eyes aren't functioning very well
you can't really see
they're going to work on your eyes and
they're going to make you see a little
bit better
this presumes that things have a purpose
and that your body parts have a purpose
but we deny that now in our culture we
deny that our body parts have any
purpose we deny
purpose entirely or the technical term
t-loss
and so because we deny that things get a
little kooky
where you say well anything can be or do
any other thing
and now the purpose of medicine has
transformed from fixing things and
making them do what they're supposed to
do
pursuing justice to
fantasy to creating fantasies and
turning people into all sorts of things
that they are not and that they they
really ought not to be
now this is all done in the name of
compassion and in the name of pride it's
very prideful
it's very prideful to say that we can
recreate the world according to our own
fancies and that we have the right to do
that and that we ought to do that
and that the world will be much better
not
according to nature and pursuing justice
but according to our own fantasies and
our own basis desires
the the pride issue is so much bigger
than sex
everyone wants to make it just about the
gays you know or just about that
now i guess including transgender
whatever it's about so much more than
that it's about a
leftist political program to
transform all of reality that the idea
that we can redefine reality by
redefining words
a thesis advance in my opinion book
speechless controlling writes and
telling that's available now for
pre-order
it's what whitaker chambers said is the
the second oldest
ideology in the world that began in the
garden of eden when the serpent told eve
shall be his gods
but that's what this is about that's
what constructing someone's
body to look like something that they
never were
is about ring my bell
l l ring my bell
my bill ring my belt just ring it click
it right now right now do it you
subscribe you'll get the notifications
and head on over
to apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher myspace
xanga aol instant messenger wherever we
have our audio podcast
please subscribe leave a five star
review we really appreciate it we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you